turning red like all of pixar's films
went through a huge development period
from a general idea to concept art to
dropped plotlines and even a few
animation mistakes we're taking a look
at everything we could get our paws on
number one just like mei was going
through changes so was the panda maze
red panda went through some pretty
drastic changes in the film originally
the panda was going to grow and shrink
depending on how emotional mei was but
this led to complications for the
animation team when deciding how big to
make her domi she said the more angry
she'd get the bigger and more feral
she'd look the size of the panda
constantly changing was going to cause
more problems for mei adding even more
comedy to situations where she'd be too
small or too big do you think there is
any particular emotion attached to mei's
ears or tail popping out only we're
assuming it's just an anime thing
inspiration inuyasha in this concept art
it looks like the pandas also had
firepowers we can see why this would
complicate the whole magical puberty
thing just a bit too much but there may
have been remnants of the fire in may in
this next bit of concept art may can be
seen with what's either blue smoke or
fire coming out of her ears and tail
while we're pretty sure this idea was
replaced with the poof of pink smoke
it's still pretty cool to see and the
spiral design that's a symbol of her
great ancestor became limited to just
her arms in the end which we bet made
animating her much easier
number two we're glad they didn't
destroy all of toronto in this movie you
know how we were talking about may
changing sizes well turning red had an
alternate ending where may was going to
grow to the size of her mom's red panda
and the two were going to tear up
toronto in an epic godzilla-like battle
pretty sweet huh luckily they pared that
down to just ming being gigantic which
minimalized the damage costs they would
be on the hook to cover
number three it's amazing how plots
evolve
because speaking of damage there was an
alternate plot altogether that the final
scene of the movie showed of the family
slowly paying off the sky dome before it
became that scene it was an entire plot
in the movie where ming was the one
encouraging her daughter to turn into a
panda to raise money for their family
temple of course this manifested in more
ways than paying to repair the skydome
it also became the story of may raising
money for four town tickets
number four so you come to me on the day
of my daughter's wedding yes there was
indeed a gangster in chinatown named
benny blacktooth in the first draft of
the screenplay the temple had fallen
onto hard times and so they owed quite a
lot of money to this blacktooth
character domi she admitted the first
version was so kooky we just really went
for all out like a goofy steven chaos
kind of screwball kind of comedy but it
wound up way too complicated domi
brought this draft to a halt when she'd
said wait wait wait we were talking
about magical puberty why are there
gangsters in this they had done their
research talking to san francisco
chinatown experts who discussed the
warring chinatown gangs but we will
admit we're glad they took a different
approach it would have made the movie
far less relatable there was even this
weird bit of concept art where 13 year
old panda may was officiating at a
gangster wedding
number five this would have made for
either a depressing story or a
completely absurd one another abandoned
draft focused far more on family and far
less on may growing up when it took
place at her grandmother's funeral in
this version she would be meeting her
extended family for the first time
meaning we would see so much more of all
those kooky ants we love so much in the
film in this draft mae and her mom have
a rivalry against a cousin and an aunt
who could still turn into their pandas
we're in love with the concept art for
the little cousin who had a tail more
like a raccoon so at one point it wasn't
only the women of the family who turned
into pandas this story was scrapped for
being too plot focused and lost sight of
may's journey through magical puberty
number six dropping the references that
today's youth wouldn't understand was a
good idea some of the names were changed
as the plot of the movie developed may
was originally named faye and four town
was called boys and streets that's right
it was spelled with a z because that was
the cool thing in the era of boy bands
that and all things numbers there was at
least 20 different titles for turning
red too from the notorious rpg rpg
meaning red panda girl a play on the
name of the rapper my neighbor toronto a
play on my neighbor totoro pms panda
mayhem syndrome you can figure that one
out girl in red panda prime anything but
red big deal and faily and a panda to
name a few
number seven saving the planet one cut
scene at a time we completely lost one
scene that was fully animated that was
included in the trailer and the making
of documentary on disney plus mei and
her friends were protesting to save the
planet in the making of doc we lost this
weird little moment of the girls
flopping on the floor in an attempt to
draw attention to their cause this was
most likely cut due to it not reflecting
mei's goody two-shoes straight a values
it was better to highlight how perfect
she is in that she wasn't even
attempting to disrupt the system but
that doesn't mean the environment isn't
important guys just that mei doesn't
seem like the type to protest we do
however see how it made it to completion
before being cut
number eight the beavers are not happy
about this one there was a quirky
canadian joke that wound up being
replaced with a just as quirky triangle
joke tragically we lost the line are you
a beaver cause damn
and instead we got are you a triangle
cause you were cute
the geometry joke works fine but we're
still sad about it hey maybe a red panda
would be attracted to a beaver who knows
and maybe that would take the magical
puberty metaphor a step too far for a
children's movie hmm
number nine these are just the scrapped
pages they were willing to show us some
pages were drafted up for may's notebook
that we never even got to see including
a page of devin as a centaur and all of
may's friends dressed up as sailor moon
characters this bit was a nod to one of
the major influences of the film the
anime style and pastel colors of sailor
moon were the color palette they used in
turning red another reference to sailor
moon can be seen hanging on the wall in
this concept art including everybody's
favorite number two character luigi with
toad not that we ever expected the
characters to make it into the movie
given the ip isn't owned by disney but
it's still cute to see did you know domi
she's parents still have some of her
drawings that influenced the notebook
scene
number 10. it's like a light bulb one
day it's off the next day we're obsessed
that's a pretty bad metaphor unless
you're a moth we can all relate to this
one i didn't even like sport town last
year but now they're literally the
greatest thing this scene we imagine was
in the opening shot of the movie where
may's narrating if this was staged at
her house it makes sense to cut it
because of course ming is not a huge fan
of mae's friend group hip hoppers and
why are they called fourth town if there
are five of them
number eleven and speaking of watching
tv there's also this sweet bit of
concept art of may and ming crying while
holding each other and watching tv we
did get a truncated version of this in
the movie and there was no crying
involved instead they were sassing the
poorly contrived plot of the show
leading to the assumption that they're
watching some sort of soap opera
number 12 which makes for better
character development only child
syndrome or oldest child syndrome and
another deleted character by the looks
of it in one draft may have a baby
sibling this most likely was in a pretty
early draft of the movie with the kooky
ants at the funeral it added to the
mother-daughter dynamic to have may be
the only child so she could be
completely smothered by her mother's
love and expectations and not have that
attention divided between another child
although it would have been added
responsibility and expectations put on
may so perhaps they could have worked a
sibling into the mix either way not
necessary
number 13
we're going to get real for a second now
disney has been going through some
serious controversy this past bit over
what's been going on in florida and it's
theorized that there are lgbtq plus
scenes that have been cut out of turning
red priya obviously has affections for
the goth girl at the party but their
moments together are slim to none and
even downright jarring given there's
just a tiny knot at the moment the two
characters share pixar employees across
the movies are frustrated and have been
coming out to say that they have
constantly been shut down trying to
include more lgbtq plus content
number 14 torontonians know best we bet
they pointed it out first one mistake
that wasn't caught until it was already
released on disney plus was the toronto
streetcar you don't need a steering
wheel when the street car follows a
track the old street cars just had
buttons now the new high tech ones have
multiple screens but still
no steering wheel number 15. last time
we checked the super power was to turn
into a panda not to conjure incense
there was also one we mistake when
manghan's may incent sticks ming is
holding four and she gives may 3. then
ming is still holding three
number 16 we're refraining from making a
joke about sight when mei's dad is
making food in true anime fashion his
glasses get steamed up when he wipes
them clean he only wipes one lens but
suddenly both are clear okay well thanks
for listening so the creative team had
to make some hard choices cutting out so
much juicy stuff but we have to say
we're glad they stuck with the plotline
they did there's no space for gangsters
in this story there was barely space for
the kooky ants if you could have brought
any deleted elements back into the movie
what would you choose we'd bring back
priya's extended arc if it exists which
you know it was at least talked about
among the creatives let us know your
thoughts in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things